buongiorno a tutti tanto potenziale
grazie per l'accoglienza
l'applauso beh devo dire già che siamo
in sintonia siamo incollata partiamo
subito proprio da questo come state
una buona notizia partiamo proprio bene
il senso stesso della parola e bene e
siete felici sì grazie alla cucina
labonia di noi guardiamo disco siete
felici e state bene avete un sogno
perfetto in natura non esistono giusto e
lo sbagliato esiste ciò che in
equilibrio e ciò che invece non lo re
noi siamo esseri umani non dico uomini
perché mi sembra molto equilibrato
la proposta di equilibrio siamo esseri
umani ma cosa ci rende tali se lo
chiedete a qualcuno che una situazione
più o meno scientifica vi risponderà il
pollice opponibile o qualcosa del genere
ma anche un primato e una scimmia anno
il pollice opponibile altri potrebbero
invece magari impostare la questione
filologica filosofica sul fatto che
essere umano significa per la percezione
del tempo e quindi organizzarlo
teoricamente anche un computer allora un
essere umano
in tali casi potrebbe essere anche ma
proviamo inter mix tra queste due cose
che ci rende tali la capacità di vedere
nel tempo un qualcosa e poi volerla
realizzare desiderare con tutto se
stessi la realizzazione di questo
qualcosa quindi siamo uomini c'è un
equilibrio siamo esseri umani che siamo
in equilibrio se sappiamo sognare e
tendere alla realizzazione di questo
sogno ma come faccio a realizzare
appunto un sogno prima di tutto devo
ammettere di averlo la maggioranza delle
persone non ammettono di avere un
desiderio qualcosa che va al di là di
loro è proprio una cosa che evade da
questa natura in realtà anche questo è
già sognare
molte persone dicono io non sono
competitivo ed è spesso un muro per il
fatto che magari non riescono a
resistere a quelli che sono i sintomi
della
competizione perché ce n'è di molti
generi la tensione la paura è un
meccanismo di difesa
la nostra mente e spesso il nostro
alleato ma anche il nostro nemico invece
deve essere semplicemente appunto un
alleato noi stessi noi siamo la nostra
mente io voglio realizzare il mio sogno
e non lo abbandono prima che lui mi
abbandoni sono su sentieri invisibili
che vedo solo io poi pian piano le
persone che mi vogliono bene persone che
contagio col mio desiderio crederanno in
quel qualcosa
saranno con un piede su quel sentiero e
quindi saranno già nel sogno la mia
immagine onirica non inizia al
raggiungimento inizia oggi
allora vediamo cosa si può fare abbiamo
se per esempio utilizziamo i vari canti
perché la nostra vita è un insieme di
campi che assemblati in sinergia in
sincretismo concorrono alla
realizzazione del sogno
uno di questi campi può essere per
esempio le telecomunicazioni che noi
tutti utilizziamo anche adesso per
esempio le telecomunicazioni parlano
dell'onda sonoro dell'ordine in genere
quindi un'onda armonica su cui
appoggiano tutte le altre l'onda
armonica il nostro sogno
tutte le altre sono tutto ciò che
facciamo nella vita quelli insieme
quell'aria quella musica è il concorso
al sogno
noi possiamo realizzare a questo modo
pensate a quegli individui che hanno
magari un incidente gravissimo e di
colpo hanno la realtà davanti
normalmente la verità quella che
potremmo chiamare verità per noi
ovviamente la nostra visione soggettiva
estremamente soggettiva è come un vetro
appannato in quei momenti lucidi noi
passiamo una mano su questo vetro non
vediamo tutto soppesiamo tutto quando
avete un incidente lo dico da alpinista
non succede veramente che vi passa la
vita davanti però è vero che nel dopo
quando realizzate avete la concessione
di quello che è successo una visione
globale di quello che davvero vi
interessa e perdono di vista tante cose
su perde di vista veramente inutile
spesso confondiamo l'essere con l'avere
abbiamo una quantità di bisogni indotti
perfettamente inutile l'ultimo
telefonino
l'ultima tecnologia sono dei mezzi
niente perché mezzi il sogno un'altra
cosa
non è che salumi di my phone allora
raggiunto il mio sogno o se sono più
ganzo per usare un termine classico se
ho bevuto di più arrivo a casa la sera
apro la porta il gatto alto come me dice
qualcosa che non va come si usa adesso
qual quadrana cosa no non va bene c'è
qualcosa che non abbiamo il diritto a un
sogno prima di tutto lo inquadriamo qual
è il nostro sogno noi passiamo la vita
verso il sogno che sia per conquistarlo
guadagnarselo chi sia per abbandonarlo
prima permessi abbandoni ci abbandoni ma
concorriamo tutta la vita qualsiasi
momento cosa stai facendo cosa state
facendo in questo momento per concorrere
al vostro sogno adesso che siete su
questa sedia che state ascoltando me
state già facendo qualcosa tutta la
vostra vita che l'insieme degli elementi
compreso questo istante stanno puntando
le e magari non viene ancora
cosa succede che a un certo punto vi
chiedete ma io ho il diritto di essere
felice
c'è un momento nella vita magari quando
non dico un incidente ma quando siete in
quel barlume come la palla che non ha
lanciato in aria per un attimo c'è
quella lucidità il diritto di essere
felice molte persone come la parola
ricada una terra rimbalzano perdono
energia cinetica altri magari hanno
sotto i piedi un tessuto fatto di sabbia
e la sabbia ingloba questa palla altri
invece sono come una biglia che scivola
e prende energia e non è più facile
arrestarla poi non è più possibile
arrestarla
questa cosa ciò che facciamo abbiamo
diritto a essere felice o su un uomo è
diventato il più potente uomo al mondo
con yes we can
direi che si può fare da questa e la
franchezza però si può fare veramente si
potrebbe anche dire fate della vostra
vita un capolavoro ma anche questa credo
che l'abbiano già usata quindi è
tendenzialmente difficile battute a
parte la domanda quindi è io voglio
credere al mio sogno e nessuno può
impedirmi di raggiungerlo di pensare
adesso come fare sono un alpinista penso
a giusto gervasutti convinceva se mi
fosse dato di vivere senza un sogno alla
capacità di avere un sogno bello quanto
inutile sarei un uomo finito ora
utilizza la tecnica alpinistica tutte le
volte che mi sono trovato veramente il
confine tra morte e vita hanno fatto una
cosa semplice uno scalo una montagna di
coppa scandalo quella montagna
so che a rivoli ma ma arriverò fino a
quel sasso quando sono arrivato al sasso
arriverò a quel tronco di legno e poi a
per la foglia e poi alla parete e poi a
quella sosta anche al singolo passaggio
e poi mi trovo sulla montagna ma il
primo passo che ho fatto ero già sul
sentiero ero già sul mio sogno
poi ci sono teorie più moderne la prima
volta che ho ascoltato un discorso
gestionale da cinque anni fa primo due
anni fa poi ancora le teorie mini con
miglioramento continuo ma il calcio è
teoria del ciclo di them in the money
migliorare ogni singolo tassello e
andare avanti e continuare qui la mente
continua a difendersi sia il diritto a
essere felice ma pensa a quelle che non
hanno niente pensa a quelli che hanno
problemi di qui e di là pensa quelle che
stanno male se ci penso ma devo essere
anche felice e non vuol dire con ismo
intendiamoci perché il sogno può essere
utilizzato per qualsiasi cosa
decido che utilizzerò la mia illusione
la mia possibilità per fare qualcosa di
buono
posso fare beneficenza solidarietà va
qualcosa che io reputo giusto senza un
peso ma allora qual è il problema
nessuno essere non avere lancia il
problema questo fatto è tanto semplice
ma c'è il problema l'importante è
partire e provare l'importante è
crederci io
vedo il sogno provo a raggiungerlo mi
manca tempo ma allora la famiglia la
famiglia deve far parte del sogno il
tempo altra tecnica si dice ottimizzare
il tempo non è possibile ottimizzare il
tempo il tempo non si comprime né si
dilata sono percezioni nostre è
possibile organizzarlo la classica
abbattuta della persona che più o meno
ha capito come organizzare il suo tempo
è tutto a posto
vado in macchina faccio le telefonate in
macchina ragione arrivo non solo fatto
la telefonata che hanno perso tempo ma
ho uno spazio in più e sono più
rilassato per pensarmi ma io ho solo
un'ora al giorno non riesco come faccio
a tirar fuori un ora al giorno x 7
giorni sono 7 gen sette ore di lavoro
una giornata dedicata al sogno x 52
settimane praticamente ho un lavoro
verso il mio sogno più ampio del numero
di ferie che faccio e vado avanti così
allora la ribalta al contrario
immaginiamo che adesso siamo qua in
questa bella sala passa il tempo più o
meno tutti noi vivremo credo al massimo
un ottantina danni ancora chi più chi
meno
io dovrei arrivare quasi a 120 per cui
ma io 120 ci arrivò però sicuro arrivo a
questi bellissimi 80 anni da adesso in
poi e vado avanti e vivo perché poi la
vita si allunga e ci sono figli che ci
sono ipotesi ci sono feste e mi ricordo
quel che c'è quella vacanza e compro
l'iphone e se voglio vado allo stadio se
voglio guardo le veline e miss taglia
questo e quell'altro benissimo poi
arriva nel momento in cui è finito il
mio tempo la crisi delle scaduta e dov'è
finito quel sogno che avevo non mi
ricordo nemmeno più il momento in cui ho
smesso di poter credere che si sarebbe
realizzato è già successo tutto non
posso tornare indietro
la mia vita è finita e calcola qualcosa
di infinito
e questo che siamo qualsiasi cosa e se
noi siamo credenti o meno non importa
però c'è una mente dentro un corpo di
carne che segue leggi finite e cerca di
misurare infinito e da una cosa
impossibile
io non riesco a capire sarò morto fino a
perché questa la sensazione sparirò però
poi dopo cento anni dopo mille dopo un
milione di anni no non c'è al poi è
finito comunque che sia questa forma di
energia non ci sarà più
io cristiano non ci sarò più e nessuno
potrà chiamarvi e io mi volterò di nonna
mi chiamano conivolto però non succederà
ma anche questa cosa allora no torno
indietro
torno ad oggi alla poltrona al discorso
a questo tappeto la telecamera tornare
adesso adesso tutto davanti posso farlo
e allora qui che ho capito di avere il
diritto di essere felice ho capito che
c'è un modo per farlo ci sono qualche
aiuto basilare ma è tutto già lì davanti
a me ho la consapevolezza di volerlo
fare
cosa manca solo una cosa che primo passo
capire che nel momento che io faccio il
primo passo e decido che non smetterò
mai di credere che questa cosa
non si possa realizzare il sun si
realizzerà filosoficamente per prendere
un altro aiuto si potrebbe dire che io
faccio il primo passo e se davvero non
mollerò mai
in un tempo non so in che l'uovo non so
quando quel sogno è già avvenuto già
adesso in questo momento se parlo io
c'è un christian che ha già realizzato
il suo sogno semplicemente non sa né
dove né quando
ma già successo e non sacrifica la
famiglia questo quest'altro perché avrei
mille esempi di persone che potevano
smettere di credere al trasforma proprio
fonio keep you spare solidarietà che più
per fine sportivo da messi a messner a
martin luther king a miliardi di altri
ma non ha fatto hanno continuato a
credere ma anche degli esempi più
semplici mi viene in mente un ragazzo di
qualche anno fa si deve prenderlo nella
mia sfera quella alpinistica un
arrampicatore e si chiama gianluca
daniele ha messo su famiglia per un
bravo arrampicatore ha deciso che da
quando ha messo su famiglia
salendo a mezzo retta un'oretta prima di
accompagnare i figli a scuola
dovrei vedere la storia precisa ma non è
non è la precisione importante si
ricavava un pezzettino di tempo per sé
quando non toglieva la famiglia e la
domenica con la famiglia andava nei
boschi a scalare tutti insieme 200
tentativi su una via risalita si chiama
grandi gesti dopo il nome della via di
scalata ha fatto il dodicesimo grado 9 a
più nove ha affatto una delle
prestazioni più grandi che ci siano mai
state
e l'ha fatto insieme alla sua famiglia
essa ha concorso al suo sogno il suo
sogno il loro sogno era una cosa buona
anche perché mentre lui faceva quello
che la sua compagnia poteva scalare
quando i boschi che era quello che lei
voleva insieme potevano vedere figli il
cui sogno iniziale da noi mi poteva
avere quello due genitori che si amano e
che concorrono a un sogno comune l'ha
vissuto quando è partito non sapeva che
ce l'avrebbe fatta come messner quando è
partito non sapeva che poteva veramente
scalare da essere ultra il settimo grado
il sesto e al massimo limite delle
capacità umane
potremmo fare miliardi di esempi il
risultato pratico anche loro hanno
creduto in un sogno l'ha vissuto la
domanda al contrario cioè è già avvenuto
bisogna solo mettersi ripartire essere
non avere quindi mi chiedo cosa posso
fare per che nulla possa concorrere a
distruggere il mio sogno
semplicemente respirarlo lasciarmi
andare vivan organizza un mio tempo
tolgo quella patina ammetto che potrò
sbagliare
ammetto che continuerò a provarci e non
faccio altro che ri scoprire chi sono
ciò che veramente sono è quella persona
al di là di questo percorso
io fra un tot di anni pensiero a questo
momento mi ricorderò del tappeto rosso
della poltrona
mi ricorderò delle telecamere mi
ricordano di voi magari voi vi
ricorderete di me e mi ricorderò di
quando fatto questo gesto e adesso non
posso più tornare indietro
ora si sogna
grazie